The first is column drop.
Column drop is probably the easiest.
At its narrowest viewport,
each element simply stacks vertically,
one on top of the other.
As things get wider,
the elements expand,
until the first break point is hit.
At the first break point, instead
of having all the elements stacked,
two elements are now side by side.
And the third element is underneath.
The elements keep expanding as the
viewport gets wider until the next break
point is hit.
And then,
things reflow to a three-column layout.
Generally, once the viewport hits a
maximum width, the columns hit a maximum
size, and instead of getting wider,
margins are added to the left and right.
So how do we code this?
Let's start with the smallest viewport.
We have our three divs,
inside of a container div.
The container is a flex container,
with flex-wrap, wrap.
Next, I've set the width of
all of the divs to 100% to
give me that stacked layout.
Because this is just a sample,
I'll pick a totally random
break point at 450 pixels.
I want that dark blue div to be
25% of the viewport width, and
the light blue div to be 75%.
And I want to keep the green
at the full width.
I'm going to add a new media query that
checks if min width is greater than or
equal to 450 pixels, and then change
the width of dark blue to 25 and
light blue to 75%.
I'll add a third break point at 550
pixels and make the dark blue div 25%,
the light blue div 50%, and
the green div to be 25%.
To get that to happen, I'll add
a new media query that tests for
screen, and min-width 550 pixels.
Inside that media query,
I'll set the width for
dark blue and green to 25% and
light blue to 50%.
Let's try it in the browser.
We're all stacked at 400 pixels.
At 450, our layout changes,
and again at 550 pixels.
Perfect.